in Dublin.
(Laughter)
But she's on her way.
This is the last piece.
This is about the supposed arrival at the sum of all of our endeavors.
In Santiago itself --
it could be Santiago,
it could be Mecca,
it could be Varanasi,
it could be Kyoto,
it could be that threshold you've set for yourself,
the disturbing approach to the consummation of all your goals.
And one of the difficulties about walking into your life,
about coming into this body,
into this world fully,
is you start to realize
that you have manufactured three abiding illusions
that the rest of humanity has shared with you since the beginning of time.
And the first illusion is that you can somehow construct a life
in which you are not vulnerable.
You can somehow be immune to all of the difficulties
and ill health and losses
that humanity has been subject to since the beginning of time.
If we look out at the natural world,
there's no part of that world
that doesn't go through cycles of, first, incipience,
or hiddenness,
but then growth, fullness,
but then a beautiful, to begin with, disappearance,
and then a very austere, full disappearance.
We look at that, we say, "That's beautiful,
but can I just have the first half of the equation, please?
And when the disappearance is happening,
I'll close my eyes and wait for the new cycle to come around."
Which means most human beings are at war with reality
50 percent of the time.
The mature identity
is able to live in the full cycle.
The second illusion is,
I can construct a life in which I will not have my heart broken.
Romance is the first place we start to do it.
When you're at the beginning of a new romance or a new marriage,
you say, "I have found the person who will not break my heart."
I'm sorry;
you have chosen them out unconsciously for that exact core competency.
(Laughter)
They will break your heart.
Why?
Because you care about them.
You look at parenting, yeah?
Parenting: "I will be the perfect mother and father."
Your children will break your heart.
And they don't even have to do anything spectacular or dramatic.
But usually, they do do something spectacular or dramatic --
(Laughter)
to break your heart.
And then they live with you as spies and saboteurs for years,
watching your every psychological move,
and spotting your every weakness.
And one day,
when they're about 14 years old,
with your back turned to them,
in the kitchen,
while you're making something for them --
(Laughter)
the psychological stiletto goes in.
(Applause)
And you say, "How did you know exactly where to place it?"
(Laughter)
And they say,
"I've been watching you for --
(Laughter)
a good few years."
And then we hope that our armored, professional personalities
will prevent us from having our heart broken in work.
But if you're sincere about your work,
it should break your heart.
You should get to thresholds
where you do not know how to proceed.
You do not know how to get from here to there.
What does that do?
It puts you into a proper relationship with reality.
Why?
Because you have to ask for help.
Heartbreak.
We don't have a choice about heartbreak,
we only have a choice of having our hearts broken
over people and things and projects that we deeply care about.
And the last illusion is,
I can somehow plan enough and arrange things
that I will be able to see the path to the end
right from where I'm standing,
right to the horizon.
But when you think about it,
the only environment in which that would be true
would be a flat desert,
empty of any other life.
But even in a flat desert,
the curvature of the earth would take the path away from you.
So, no;
you see the path,
and then you don't
and then you see it again.
So this is "Santiago,"
the supposed arrival,
which is a kind of return to the beginning all at the same time.
We have this experience of the journey,
which is in all of our great spiritual traditions,
of pilgrimage.
But just by actually standing in the ground of your life fully,
not trying to abstract yourself into a strategic future
that's actually just an escape from present heartbreak;
the ability to stand in the ground of your life
and to look at the horizon that is pulling you --
in that moment,
you are the whole journey.
You are the whole conversation.
"Santiago."
"The road seen, then not seen
the road seen, then not seen
the hillside hiding then revealing the way you should take
the hillside hiding then revealing the way you should take,
the road dropping away from you
as if leaving you to walk on thin air,
then catching you,
catching you,
holding you up, when you thought you would fall,
and the way forward
the way forward always in the end
the way that you came,
the way that you followed, the way that carried you into your future,
that brought you to this place,
no matter that it sometimes had to take your promise from you,
no matter that it always had to break your heart along the way:
the sense
the sense of having walked from deep inside yourself
out into the revelation,
to have risked yourself
for something that seemed to stand both inside you and far beyond you,
and that called you back in the end
to the only road you could follow,
walking as you did, in your rags of love
and speaking in the voice that by night became a prayer for safe arrival,
so that one day
one day you realized
that what you wanted had actually already happened
and long ago
and in the dwelling place in which you lived before you began,
and that
and that every step along the way,
every step along the way,
you had carried the heart and the mind and the promise
that first set you off and then drew you on,
and that
and that you were more marvelous
in your simple wish to find a way
you were more marvelous in your simple wish to find a way
than the gilded roofs of any destination you could reach
you were more marvelous in that simple wish to find a way
than the gilded roofs of any destination you could reach:
as if, all along,
you had thought the end point might be a city with golden domes,
and cheering crowds,
and turning the corner
at what you thought was the end of the road,
you found just a simple reflection,
and a clear revelation beneath the face looking back
and beneath it another invitation,
all in one glimpse
all in one glimpse:
like a person
like a person or a place you had sought forever
like a person or a place you had sought forever,
like a bold field of freedom that beckoned you beyond;
like another life
like another life,
and the road
the road still stretching on."
(Applause)
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
You're very kind. Thank you.
(Applause)